[Music]
well I just published this magnificent
book on humor I cut I keep rereading it
just to relish the witch and the
wordplay the Swift perceptiveness of it
why you try very very hard for me to
tear myself away from it to come here
and the first chapter of it as you'll
find out very shortly when you buy a
copy is on laughter and it's epigraph is
actually an old joke from Bob Monkhouse
you've probably heard it they laughed
and I said I wanted to be a comedian
well they're not laughing now Samuel
Johnson always an excellent way to start
a sentence Samuel Johnson remarks
somewhere that though human beings have
been wise in different ways they've
always laughed in the same way now
that's surely doubtful in it I mean
laughter is a language with a whole host
of different idioms cackling chortling
grunting chuckling shrieking bellowing
screaming sniggering gasping shouting
braying yelping I go on there like this
for a half an hour absolutely roaring
chittering hooting guffawing snorting
howling screeching bellowing snickering
and so on
what about what I missed out there's a
prize for somebody giggling yes prize
the prizes you can buy two copies in
this world well the paradoxes of
laughter is in one sentence a pure
enunciation without any which expresses
nothing but itself in a way without any
inherent sense in a way like music but
though it like though it lacks intrinsic
sense rather like an animal's cry decart
described laughter as an inarticulate
and explosive cry but despite that fact
despite the fact that it
in a way and matter purely of the
signifier yet it doesn't have a meaning
or signifies it's richly laden with
cultural significance yes so it's sort
of as it were on the cusp of nature and
culture not only has laughed a no
inherent meaning in the way that a
sentence does but at its most righteous
or convulsive if it involves the
disintegration of meaning as the body
tears one speech to fragments and the
aid pitches the ego into temporary
disarray as with grief or severe pain or
extreme fear or blind rage truly
uproarious laughter of course involves a
loss of physical self-control as the
body body gets moments really out of
hand and we regress to the uncoordinated
state of the of the infant laughed at
laughter is quite literally a bodily
disorder something alarmingly animal
about it not least the kind of noise it
involved you know hooting braying
cackling name here I go again bellowing
and son which calls to mind our affinity
with the other animals which is strange
because the other animals don't laugh
themselves at least not conspicuously so
Darwin thought that monkeys chuckles
when you tickle them I don't know if
anybody's tickled a monkey recently to
try and put this to the test so that in
this sentence oddly laughter that wants
animal and distinctively human it's a
mining of the noise of the beasts on the
one hand it's quite unbe
laughter signifies but it also involves
a breakdown of signification into pure
spasm breath sound rhythm and so on it
represents in one sense the temporary
collapse or derangement of what we might
call the symbolic order of meaning well
in another sense it continues always to
rely upon it because we laugh for some
kind of Reason yes normally speaking
except the laughter kind of course
generate more laughter and that it
become contagious where we don't even
know what we're laughing I'll accept
were laughing at laughing so laughter is
an utterance which Springs straight from
the libidinal depths of the body but
there's a cognitive Thai mentioned to it
as well as there is to all emotions all
emotions emotions involve ideas of some
kind yes
well laughing it's something after all
infant smile almost from birth but
laughter begins only around the third or
fourth months perhaps of its need to
engage the mind in some way laughter
isn't always a laughing matter
there's a cliche for you there have even
been lethal epidemics of the stuff in
China Africa Siberia and elsewhere mass
historical paroxysm 'z in which so it's
alleged thousands of people have died
died literally of laughter in 1962 one
such outbreaks in what was then an
Janica immobilized whole school
districts for months on end and since
being out of control is never entirely
pleasurable laughter can easily border
on the unpleasant like being tickled
example so I'm told I've never actually
been you know people have told my friend
tells me that your being and in fact
Johnson Samuel Johnson in his dictionary
defines laughter as convulsive merriment
which is almost an oxymoron isn't it
almost self-contradictory like business
my favorite oxymoron Samuel Beckett once
said he had a strong weakness for an
oxymoron
lying through his teeth
the narrator of Lawrence Stearns great
novel Tristram Shandy tells us he once
laughed so hard as he broke a blood
vessel and lost four pints of blood in
two hours
the novelist Anthony Trollope suffered a
stroke were laughing at a comic novel a
misfortune by which few of his own
readers are likely fixes so you can
treat languages that laughter as a kind
of text if you like or the language with
so many different regional accents
you know upper-class Englishmen are more
likely to Bray than middle class English
women who have perhaps a more given to
tinkling yes military generals tend not
to giggle or pokes to cackles for
example the president of the World Bank
is committed to laughs heartily but not
hysterically begins to have economic
worries if he starts laughing
hysterically quite a lot of humor
involves what Freud calls D sublimation
let's say basically debunk re puncturing
you know the energy is that we invest in
some ideal or just in some meaning or
value but it doesn't have to be that
idea are released as laughter those
psychic energies are released in the
form of rupture when the ideal is rudely
punctured because sustaining ideals
involves or even values which involves a
certain degree of psychical strain so
not having to do so can be a pleasurable
sensation we're now free from having to
maintain a reputable moral France and
can reap the delectable fruits of being
shamelessly crude cynical selfish
lecherous insulting morally indolent
emotionally anesthetized and
outrageously self-indulgence all of
which of course is very peasant but we
can
also be enjoyably release according to
psychoanalytic theory not only from from
the from ideals but from the very
exigencies of sense making our continual
and routine sense making itself
psychoanalytically involves a degree of
psychical investment yes what Freud
calls the compulsion of logic a process
which involves unwelcome constraints on
the anarchic in the anarchic unconscious
so hence our delight in the surreal or
absurd world in which anything is
possible in which log which is
unshackled from logic as for example in
one of the goon shows that some people
here will remember and since I was born
in the early years of the Industrial
Revolution I remember in which they had
a crafty idea of floating a life-sized
cardboard replica of the British Isles
off the British Isles to bamboozle
German bombers when they were that kind
of thing remaining serious in other
words psychologically speaking or
psychoanalytically speaking involves
successful repression a mild kind of
repression another crippling neurotic
depression and joking is therefore a
brief vacation from the mild
oppressiveness of meanings
jokes buck the tyranny of what Freud
calls a reality principle they afford as
a certain infantile satisfaction as we
regress to a condition which predates
the jealously enforced divisions and
Precision's of the symbolic order and
are able to throw logic linearity
congruity and so on to the wind for
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you